por segunda vez en dos años paul y su
hija tienen que vivir en una casa
rodante su hogar en paradise fue
destruido por el incendio can fire en
2018 y acababan de rehacer su vida en
bear creek pero hace una semana la
familia tuvo que huir de nuevo
pensé que conducir a través del camp air
era horrible pero esta vez fue aún peor
el fuego generaba su propia tormenta con
llamas que brotaban a ambos lados del
camino no podía ver a más de 50 metros y
sentía el calor a través del coche
paige su hija sólo tiene 16 años tuvo
que ir en coche para poner a salvo a las
mascotas en folkestone sam ting estar
concentrada en eso me mantuvo la cabeza
fría pero una vez llegué estaba a punto
de quebrar me sabía que había una
posibilidad de que no volviéramos otra
vez es muy difícil y aunque ya hemos
pasado por esto antes esta vez por qué
está sucediendo de nuevo piensa no pero
de verdad no es posible
paul no puede volver a su casa pero como
reporteros tuvimos acceso al área
quiere construir todo de nuevo
no logramos reconocer mucho aquí parece
ser una lavadora
sin embargo la familia dice estar lista
para volver a empezar aquí una vez más